[Music]
my status is single Olympian Adam Rippon
is on the market but the qualities he
wants in his dream guy are pretty simple
I mean if you've got a job and you go to
the gym let me know I guess those
standards are I feel like they could be
higher for you you gotta start somewhere
you know Adam and Mariah ngoz who
attended the 90th annual Academy Awards
together Sunday night since their rise
to fame from the Winter Olympics the
figure skating duo revealed to ET their
diems have been full thank you and Adam
appeared to have a blast at the Oscars
he even met Shawn Mendes just days
before he revealed to Ellen DeGeneres
Shawn was his celebrity crush I was
sleeping on Shawn Mendes I'm sorry I was
sleeping on Xiamen not literally but I
was I didn't realize how cute he was
uh-huh you weren't sleeping like you had
not paid attention I say yeah all right
exactly
well here's the thing those are all good
solid choices I would say I'm going to
direct you in the in the in the
direction of some some gay men
[Music]
you